تفضل عمر ان كان اي معلومات
[موسيقى]
اضافيه نعم اخر احصائيه هي كما ذكرت قبل
قليل وان عن هيئه الطوارئ الايرانيه
73 قتيلا و
171 جريحا في
الانفجارين الذين وقع بالقرب من
مقبره قاسم سليماني او المقبره التي تضم
مرقد قاسم سليماني في محافظه كرمان جنوبي
ايران المتحدث باسم الطوارئ الايرانيه قال
ان بعض الجرحى حالتهم الصحيه حرجه واضاف
ان اعداد القتلى مرجحه للارتفاع وهذا يعني
ان حصيله 73 قتيلا
و171 جريحا هي ليست احصائيه نهائيه وفق
هيئه الطوارئ الايرانيه وتحديدا المتحدث
الرسمي باسمها يجري الحديث هنا رسميا ايضا
عن ان الانفجارين هما انفجاران
اربيان اي
انهما
مدبان مساعد المساعد الامني لمحافظ كرمان
قال انهما ارهابي متفجر ارهابي واضافت
وكاله الانباء الايرانيه انهما لم يكونا
ناجم
عن انتحاريين فجرا نفسهما مثلا وانهما
ناجما عن تفجير حقيبتين مفخختين تم
تفسيرهما عن بعد اي ان هذا الحادث مدبر
وان اعداد القتلى والجرحى كانت كبيره وفق
الاحصاءات الرسميه وهي لا تزال مرجحه
لمزيد من الارتفاع لماذا نتحدث عن اعداد
كبيره بهذا الانفجار الانفجارين من القتلى
والجرحى اولا نظرا لان كان هناك حشود
كبيره تواصل مسيرها منذ ايام نحو المقبره
التي تضم مرقد قاسم سليماني ثانيا ان هذا
الانفجاران وقعا بالقرب من المقبره
وبالتالي الحشود كانت اكبر في محيط
المقبره الاجراءات الامنيه حاليا وفق
المصادر الرسميه من محافظه كرمان
جنوب ايران تقول انه تم اجلاء المقبره
التي تضم مرقد قاسم سليماني كذلك تم اجلاء
المواطنين عن المحيط محيط المقبره في تلك
المنطقه تجنبا لاي حوادث مشابهه وكذلك
ل فتح المجال للاجهزه الامنيه لاجراء
التحقيقات اللازمه من اجل
معرفه ملابسات هذه الحادثه وربما المزيد
ربما يكون هناك المزيد من الجرحى والقتلى
الناجمه عن هذين الانفجارين